they kind of send you out the room and
you're just stood in the corridor being
like did I pass did I fail oh my god I
failed I failed spectacularly
of course I failed and it's like the
worst five minutes of your life before
they like call you back in and then like
the senior professor sort of sat me down
and said congratulations dr. Smithers
and I was like oh Christ a little bit in
front of the senior professor so at
Oxford where I did my PhD they have this
really cool tradition that you pop the
champagne cup into the ceiling tile when
you come out of your viber and you sign
your name makes the dent that you leave
and you can really get to like leave
your mark on Oxford physics which is so
cool I got a first time and I think I
was more scared for that for my vibe I
was terrified of it ricocheting off the
ceiling and hitting me in the eye
like fully like nightmares about having
a black eye on the day of my Bible it's
also a binary dent which is an
astronomer I was really quite happy
about so both the both ends of the
champagne cork dented into the ceiling
because the champagne cork came out and
then came to horizontal so it looks like
a little binary star in feeling by
unusual wall yeah so I was born in
Preston and raised in Shirley sources
Lancashire I went to school in Bolton
and then I went to physics and astronomy
at Durham University I was like six
years old and what in a telescope for
Christmas kind of thing like I was
always into space like space books on
the shelf getting little telescopes
always wanting to go out and see the sky
but I hated physics so up to about G GFC
I couldn't stand physics forces and like
goes in straight lines just didn't hold
any interest for me at all and then it
took getting to TJC and starting to do
astronomy and radioactivity and exactly
that made me realise that I absolutely
loved it it's the sheer scale of space
that I thought was awesome yuria new
space books about Jupiter is so much
bigger than Earth and this is how much
more massive the Sun is and this is how
far away the moon is in
it's a kid Wow you can't even imagine
those distances and yes you can go
outside and still see it in the sky just
blew my mind it's not a little thing it
was like it I couldn't tell how big it
was I think it's like a one-inch refract
or something it was tiny but it was
really cool I could see the moon
basically and Jupiter looked like a
bigger bright spot it's been hit did
with your own eye but it was still
amazing to have I actually wanted to be
a pediatrician at one point I also
wanted to dream a marine biologist
because I loved dolphins and wanted to
work with dolphins and then my mom told
me that don't be ridiculous if you're in
a marine biologist in the UK you just
take River samples from the Thames all
day and that would be all you do not
realising that I could move outside of
the UK to do that and that also as an
astronomer I am probably now going to
end up doing that as well so at Durham I
did physics and astronomy because I knew
astronomy was something that I loved I
always wanted to do the astronomy
modules so I got to do things like
measuring the temperature of sunspots at
Durham in my second year we took solar
telescopes out of the grass in the sign
site and people looked at as like we
were crazy
but I thought it was great I got to use
the telescopes on top of the roof as
well you know shoveling six inches of
snow with a broom off the telescopes in
my third year on every clear night you
could get which meant sacrificing a lot
of nights out as a student but it was
worth it in the end of four years you're
thinking what on earth do I do now
everything up until that point has been
so sort of prescribed a little bit you
go to school you do a levels you go to a
university and then you're just left to
your own devices
and everyone's going off and applying
for grad scheme so you think okay I'll
apply for a grad scheme short and I
ended up in the September working at
Rolls Royce on their engineering grad
scheme because I never thought really
sat down about what do I want to do and
then it took me till about November to
December to realise that I missed
astronomy so much like it didn't matter
that I was kind of doing the same thing
every day
so a desk and going through data and you
know just talking to people about
science it wasn't astronomy it wasn't
the same thing and I
missed it so much that I started
applying for PhD positions in the
January
I've hired five different places so
Manchester Bristol Durham again
Oxford's four different places had
interviews all of those places not just
an interview to say they want to work
with you but also do you want to work
with them you know your supervisors
going to be supervisor for three years
you've got to like that person and I was
then just waiting to see who wanted me
where I wanted to go I got the call from
Oxford that I had been accepted on a PhD
whilst I was in Bellaire Italia in
Manchester with my mum and it was a very
excited phone call I was so happy the
project there was perfect it was working
with Galaxy Zoo which is this online
citizen science platform that gets the
public to classify galaxies which I
thought was amazing that I could do
research off the back of public effort
so my thesis was trying to figure out
why galaxies stopped forming stars so
you see a lot of blue spiral beautiful
galaxies and then you see a lot of red
boring rubbish kind of shaped galaxies
you call them elliptical galaxies and so
that areas if something blue it's very
hot it's star forming it's got lots of
young stars if it's red it's kind of
dead and dying and then it's not much
going on but the thing is you end up
seeing lots of life spirals and blue
ellipticals so it's kind of all tangled
together the shape that things are and
whether things are forming stars or not
so the idea was to use the public
classifications from galaxies do and
then all our observations of galaxies to
look at this like statistically across a
huge population like as many as you can
get hands on and see what was going on
using big population statistics
things are more complicated than they
seem that is definitely what I learned
and before people thought there was kind
of like two specific tracks that the
spiral galaxies go one way and the
elliptical galaxies go the other way
when you look at the whole population
and use statistics you see that actually
this kind of this spread of different
rates that galaxies construct forming
stars and you also find that the black
holes in the center of the galaxies play
a huge role as well and they could be
shutting down star formation really
rapidly and that also whether there's a
lot of galaxies around a galaxy or
whether the galaxy is isolated can also
have a massive impact as well and you
see that in the statistical results
which is really cool yeah this whole
heft of a thesis and in fact this is
double sided you have to print out when
you give it in single sided so it's even
higher than that when you give it and it
feels like such a weight in a meat of
work that you've done what do you think
work and astronomers who raised that was
like okay that's the new information to
me yeah I mean well that the definition
of a thesis is that you have to add
something to the scientific collective
knowledge there's also things I've added
galaxies do stop forming stars at
different rates there's not too clear
channels that's something new that
people will come to I mentioned that
black holes can have a really big impact
if supermassive ones the center of
galaxies besides learning a lot of that
star formation what did you learn about
astronomy over the three years of your
PhD that there isn't an answer and
that's where the fun bit is you know I
got into physics and astronomy and math
because I liked it over English because
there was an answer but the whole part
about research is there isn't an answer
and astronomy is beautifully complicated
and this huge big picture that is
impossible to visualize is for one
person and that collaboration between
people is crucial in order to be able to
figure it out
yeah I mean the whole you know what are
the astronomers ever done for us is is
such a repeated phrase in society and
it's not necessarily a direct thing that
we're doing you know we're not directly
curing cancer but the imaging techniques
that are being developed that we're
pushing forward like we need to see
deeper and further and more than we've
ever seen before
are then applied to things like MRI
machines and CT scans that are then used
in medicine you know astronomers needed
a better way to transfer data so they
invented bluetooth and now every single
person has that in their pocket
basically on their phone so it's the
kind of indirect things that come from
astronomy that are useful in society but
then also like humans are naturally
curious
everybody wants to know where we come
from and how the universe is and what
it's made of and those answers are going
to come ultimately from astronomy do you
think most people in the street are
curious for those
at the level you're looking at I'd hoped
that if you said to them pain is a black
hole at the center every galaxy they'd
be like really cool I hope if he said to
them you know the universe started this
way they'd at least be curious enough
and then ask follow-up questions even if
they didn't understand it they can still
be like but wait what about this I hope
there was some vestige of curiosity at
the back of everybody's minds
I got this job and basically they told
me right up your PhD as quick as you
possibly can and so I wrote it up in two
months with a 10-day holiday - squished
in the middle as well which was quite
fun and ended at Christmas which was
nice and then in the January 2nd a jam
packed up moved beside my new job on the
3rd so the whole point of this job was
that I wrote a proposal to say I want to
research this and then they picked it
because they thought that's not it cool
and so the research proposal is on this
idea of how do black holes affect their
galaxies do they stop them from forming
stars - the energy output from the black
hole sort of move through the galaxy and
you get this sort of like waves of sort
of star formation stopping or does it
put energy out into the sort of
surrounding area which then cuts off gas
supplies so there's no more star
formation this kind of thing that's what
I'm going to be focusing on I'm going to
be using this really cool new instrument
as well it doesn't just take one picture
of a galaxy it takes 127 little ones and
so you can like like sort of jigsaw
puzzle the galaxies up so that you can
see like what is going on in various
different areas
oh yeah there's loads of people working
on this coming at it from different
angles like sort of there's people
coming at it from the simulation angle
the theory angle there's people coming
at it from different wavelengths as well
I'm looking in the optical and the UV
and there's people coming at it from the
radio the x-ray and even infrared as
well so we're all working on the same
thing it's just you know to prove
something to prove a theory you need all
those little bits of observational facts
in order for it to sort of build up and
say right we're definitely sure of this
now the other part of this fellowship is
that I'm going to be working for sixty
symbols and I'm going to be making
videos about my research and what I'm
getting up to and cool things in
astronomy and what I think you guys want
to know about I've always been into
outreach you know any age basically kids
adults I think it's fantastic and for
any person if you can just help them
understand something like that light
bulb moment when they find like oh I get
it now is so gratifying
as a scientist that you've made someone
understand the world that they live in
that's true but it's a subtlety here
which is that actually what you're doing
isn't the two body problems those two
body problem is if you have to stand in
something in orbit around it what you're
actually doing is a three body problem
you've got the Sun you've got the earth
and you've got your satellite